hello my name is councillor robin dry  and i'm chairman of rocha district  council  the current circumstances we live in are  alien to us all  and bring a lot of uncertainties and new  challenges with them  for this reason i wanted to thank our  communities and businesses for pulling  together to abide by the new  restrictions  that come into force from thursday  we all still need to continue to wash  hands  cover faces and make space to control  the infection  things are not normal if you are  struggling there is help out there  the rochford community response hub  telephone number is still available  to any resident who needs it just ring  zero one two six eight seven seven  nine nine nine nine that's oh one two  six eight  seven seven nine nine nine nine  leave your name and phone number and a  short message  and somebody will call you back thank  you  and keep safe